all I know is I'm reading a love letter
I love love to me is it my is it someone
loving me now no one's loving me got it
reading I love letter the following is a
love letter from famed 20th century
Irish novelist James Joyce oh god I know
what this is - its partner Nora Barnacle
what's funny laughing dated in 1909 my
sweet little oh my god oh my sweet
little [ __ ] Nora I this is so much I
did as he told me you dirty little girl
and pulled myself off twice when I read
your letter
yeah I am delighted to see that you do
like being - hey it's Ben booty ho yes
now I can remember that night when I
thought you so long backwards it was the
dirtiest in I ever gave you darling my
prick was stuck in me for hours looking
in and out under your upturned rump
I felt your fat sweaty buttocks under my
belly and saw their flushed face in that
eyes from the back these looking ok and
every gave you your shameless tongue
came bursting out through your lips and
if I gave you a bigger stronger than
usual fat dirty farts and splurging
after your backside wow you had a nice
full of farts that night darling and I
put them out of you big fella
long long windy ones quick little Mary
cracks a lot of tiny Illuminati parties
ending in a long gush from your hole
what is this it is wonderful the a
farting woman when every drives one out
of her I think I would know Norris fart
anyway I think I could pick her out in a
room full of farting women how sweet it
is a rather girlish noise it's not like
the wet windy fart which I imagined
wives have it is sudden and dry and
dirty like what a bold girl would let
off and then funding the school
dormitory at night I hope Nora will let
off no end of her farts in my face so
that I may know their smell also good
night my little farting Nora my dirty
little Mary there's one lovely word
darling you have underlined to make me
pull myself off better write me more
about that and yourself
sweetly dirtier here is this real yeah
is this an actual letter yeah if I
didn't know any better I would think you
were really looking with me in 1909 I
thought you made this up I'm a dirty
dirty man James Joyce this is like
sexting but it's kind of beautiful
there's a lot going on in this letter I
don't kind of drop that and that's
pretty gross I feel I'm gonna go shower
[Music]
you
[Music]